顧客に対して責任を持つということと人を
育てるというこの2つですねうんでこの人
を育てるってことに対してはもちろんその
車内の研修もありますしこう日々のま同業
だったり上司からのフィードバックみたい
なところも含めて徹底されてるんですよね
だから何なのっていうこととなんでそう
考えるのってこの2つの問いかけが
ものすごい多いことに気づいたんですよ
うんこれをトレーニングするともしかし
たら論理力ってすごいつくんじゃないか
なって考え
自分で問題を解き始めてあ確かにそうだっ
ていうので確信を得てこの本書いたんです
よねえ皆さんこんにちはえ今日はですね私
あの先日私の講座の中でアシスタントに実
は入っていただいた方でま過去ねマキ勢
出身のその超一流のコンサルタントが
アシスタントに入ってるってことはなかっ
たんでそれをちょっと知りましてねあこ
この人がちょっと非常にユニークな方だな
と思ってすぐにあのブレックファストで
ですねお話をしてま一期統合してひさん
是非それではま来月からなんかハーバード
に留学するって聞いたんでその前に一度ね
是非1回色々お話しましょうと言ってそし
たらあの本を書かれてるま実は7年前に
書いた本ということなんですけども新独学
術っていう本いだきましてまこれがねま
大変内容が私これはいいなと思いましてま
今の7年前とは言ってもですね今もちろん
この現代本当にこそこそ必要な内容だなと
思ったのであのYouTubeにもね是非
出てくださいということで今日誘えました
えひ啓介さん後ほど一緒に対談しますので
楽しみにしていただきたいと思いますでは
私の方から今回のゲストであられる
バロックインベストメント代表取締役の
啓介様をご紹介させていただきます富様は
岡山県生まれバセ大学卒業後三菱商人にて
金融投資業務を担当その後歯湖大学経営
大学院にてMBAいわゆる経営学収支です
ねを取得帰国後マッキン税&カンパニーや
外資系投資ファンドであるclsa
キャピタルパートナーズにて金融消費剤
製造業など幅広い要介において経営
コンサルティング業務に従事現在は経営と
投資サービスを提供するインベストメント
の代表を務める他大手学習塾IT
コンサルティング現当初一部であったり
美容チェン原当初マザーズなど社会取締力
なども歴任社会人の学び直しをテーマとし
た新独学塾を発また京都大学博士後期家庭
にてファイナンス理論を研究し博士号も
取得されていらっしゃるとあかなり
マニアックな経歴をお持ちの方が今回
ゲストですいや本当にね非常にあの
インテリジェンスのもうねですよ本当に
素晴らしいです
さんあのこの本の中にねはいそのMB
ホルダーが必ずしもそのなんて言うん
でしょうねまある意味ではその賢いわけで
はないみたいな表現してるじゃないですか
その辺の話をねちょっとその真の賢さとは
何かということについてえちょっとお話し
ていただけますま昔みたいにこうトップの
MBからこう何かできるとかすごい給を
もらえるとかっていう世界ではなくなって
いてですねまむしろまよくドライバーズ
ライセンスみたいな言方するんですけれど
もあって当たり前ないといけない世界は
あるけれどもMBAがあったとてこうそれ
で成功するってこの保よにならないって
いう世界観にま大きく変わっていって
るっていうのがまこの本を書いた時のあの
メッセージでしたねうんなるほどでもう
ちょっと言うとですねやっぱりそのMBA
ってよくまMBAの友達と話す
やいがないからMBAたみたいな方って
意外と多いんですよねなるほどでまさっき
の話じゃないですけどやっぱ目標を設定し
たその上のところっていうのが皆さん得意
なんでMBAの授業をこなすということは
すごくうまいんですけれもなるほど
そもそもこう何をやりたいんだったっけ
みたいなことになってくるとま結構瞑想を
したりですねまいろんな方向にこうちがっ
ていくっていうようなのがま今のMBAの
ま課題感かなっていうところは思ってます
ねうんうん
コンサルティングのまお客さんっていうの
はま大企業の経営者だったりですねま
あるいはすごい会社を1台で作られたよう
な社長さんが多いわけなんですけれども
ほぼ例外なくやっぱ日本がどうなるべきな
のか今の経済環境がどうなるのかっていう
ことに関渉持たれてるのでうんまずそこと
こう会話を合わせるっていう意味でも政治
経済学びってすごくあると思うんですよね
なるうんでただそれだけではなくてうんま
よく社長もおっしゃっている心さしみたい
なことを考えていった時に自分は何のため
に生きてるんだろうかとうんうんうんで
そこを掘り下げていくと自分だけがいい
あるいは自分の会社だけがいいっていう
発想だとやっぱりどこかでこう失敗して
しまう可能性高いと思うんですよねうん
そうすると自分のこう思考を広げていった
時にやっぱり社会に対してあるいは国家に
対して何ができるのかってことを考えた時
にですね政治経済のことを知らないとこの
国がううんう流れで動いてるのかもわから
ないでそこにどういう問題があるのかも
わからないっていうま経営してもやっぱり
その社会のためになるって意味では弱いの
かなっていう風にあのますます感じてる
ところではありますねもう7年もこの本
書いてから経ちますけれどもその思いは
あのどんどん強くなってるっていう感じ
ですね
うんこれはですねまちょっと恥ずかしい話
なってしまうんですけどやっぱり高校の
教科書を読むっていうのが最も重だと思い
ますうんますねええそれはま教科書だけで
はなくて問題集も含めてなんですけれども
やっぱり我々政治経済を知らないで
いきなりこう日経新聞を読んでも分から
ない用語だとかですね分からない説明って
多いと思うんですよでそれがなぜ起こるの
かというとやっぱ圧倒的に知識が足りない
んですよねうんなるほどでその知識を補う
ことそのために何をすればいいのかって
いうことになるとやっぱ基本はですねま
大学受験用の参考書なりうん
試みでもいいとうんけそれを買ってきて
自分で解いてみてどこが理解できてて理解
できたいのかてことをチェックするって
これが一番重要な点だと思いますねま
例えば会社をこう作る時に株式会社がいい
のか合同会社がいいのか無限責に有限責に
何がいいのかって悩まれると思うんです
けどそういうことも高校の教科書に実は
書いてあるのでそこを学べばですねその
こう選択肢が広がるというか判断がし
やすくなるんですよね
[音楽]
こう仕事ができる人できない人のこう口癖
っていうねことこの本の中にも色々書いて
あるんだけどこれ思考から来ますよね口癖
そうですねその辺はどんな風にあのご自身
は捉えてますかま私自身も言ってしまっ
たりするんですけどできない人の特徴とし
てですねすぐ無理だとか私にはみたいな
ことを言い訳から入る方って結構多いん
ですよねなるほどでそうするとそこから先
っていうのができてできないとだところが
その成功されてるま経営者さんも含めて
ですねいろんなことが話してるとまずやっ
てみるって方がすごく多いなと思うんです
よねでこの本でも書かせていただいたん
ですけどまずやってみるということを言っ
た上でですねじゃあどうしようかって考え
てまこうクリエイティブなやり方を考えて
いくっていうのがやっぱりできる人の特徴
だなっていうのはすごく感じますねうん
うんうん経ってのはまさにね決断と実行
そして最後責任というま私はこの3つ非常
に重要なテーマであの決断業だと思うん
ですよ決断をしそして決断したことを必ず
実行して最後このま完結そこに責任を取る
というのはねすごく大事なことでま確かに
そのなんだろうできるできないで考えて
いくと優柔不断になってしまったりね知義
の癖がになったりうんやっぱりそういう
意味ではそういう優柔普段まの癖そして
そういう何か
こうきちっと決めれない心の状態というの
は恐れに支配されたりしてネガティブな
方向になるとやっぱり実効力不全になり
ますもんねそうですねうん確かにそれは
できないと言った瞬間に物事って終わって
しまうと思うのでま諦めたらそこで最後
っていうま有名な漫画のセリフとかあっ
たりしますけれどもまずできるやりたいっ
てことを考えた上で後から方法ついてくる
うんだと思うんですよ
ねいろんな勉強してきたけれど結局自分
探しの度結局人生の目的を探す度やっぱり
この人生の目的
がなんだろう明確になると逆算が変わる
じゃないですかはいこの目的を持って生き
てる人って意外と少ないていう話あって
ですよねで僕はねこの辺のところが今の
日本の教育のね大きなテーマだと思ってる
んですよそうですねままずその目的がある
かなしやっていうところなんですけどこれ
やっぱり学歴だとかですね今その会社とし
て成功してる成功してないってことに
関わらずやっぱりここの目的意識みたいな
ところがまある人はあるしほとんどの人が
持っていないっていう世界じゃないかなと
思ってますねうんうんうん社長がよく
おっしゃられている誰のために何のために
な私は働いているのか存在してるのか
みたいな問いかけ問いかけをされた時に
うんこズバっとこれですってことを言える
人っていうのが私も含めていないうんて
いうところにやっぱり今の教育の問題点
ってあるんじゃないかなっていうのは
すごく感じるところですねうんうん
なるほどでま特に今の教育システムって
いうのが目標から上を与えることはすごく
うまくいってる制度だと思うんですよね
うんま大学受験があったりまそこの中での
成績があったりあとま就職においてもん
みいここ入るとすいみたいなやったりする
のでそこから上のう最適みたいなとこは
すごく進んでるんですけどじゃあ昼って
自分が何をやりたいのかって考えた時にま
実はそこ答えれる人がいないっていう
ところがあのやっぱり今の日本のすごく
問題点じゃないかなという風には思います
ね
[音楽]
うんどうしたらその効率的に働けるかとか
どうしたら短時間でより高い生産性を
生み出せるかっていう方向のコンサル
ティンググってのはすごくまある意味では
ままさにインテリジェンス求められてそう
いう生産性を高めるコンサルティングって
のは技術に直結しているので世の中多いと
思うんだけど本当にウルビーング本当に人
を幸せにできる組織をどうしたら作れるの
かっていうねまそういうコンサルタントが
世の中たらいいなという風に思いますよ
ね私あの先日うちの受行生のねあの方に
あの聞いて聞いた話でね日本の大手の採用
やっているそのサイトを運営してる会社の
役員にあの本社はものすごい数のお取引き
先があるのであの是非ねそこに選択理論私
が今学んできた選択リノだとかこの
アチーブメントテクノロジーという
パーパス目的を明確にしてその本当の真の
幸せを得られるようなそういう働き方と
いうものを多くの企業に啓蒙していきたい
ので色々ご紹介してもらえませんかって
いう話をして一緒にそういうことを
ビジネスでやりませんかて言ったらその
役員の人に何て言われたかて言うと全く
興味がないとあなぜならうちは人がやめて
もらわないと商売にならないんだとああ
そういう風に言われたで僕はねその人は
それでがっくり来たわけですよねでま私に
それを伝えたんだけれども僕これぞまさに
資本主義社会のま慣れの果てって言うと変
な表現だけどはい鋭利市場主義のなん
だろうこれをみんなどうし
たら儲かるかと利益を追求した結果ですね
どんどんその人がやめるような仕組みって
いうか要は僕はね本当にこういう考え方が
問題なんじゃないかなと思ったんです
けど真の幸せって本当にこう1人1人捉え
方はあると思うんだけどこの辺のところは
もうねまさにあのマキ税出身の人さんどう
思います今の話を聞いて例えばそのマキ前
せを人が辞めるそのスパンっていうのは
日本の会社に比べるとかなり短いんですよ
ねで私がいた頃なんて多分平均で2年とか
2年半とかっていう組織でしたうんただ
マキ税っていうのはものすごい人を重要
するというか人を大切にする会社でもある
んですよあそうなのでまやめていった人
たちも含めて皆さん活躍もされていて会社
としてもすごくサポートをしてくれて
ほとんどの人がまうん働いてて良かっ
たっていう組織なんですよねそうだよねゼ
やめた人で真金悪口いう人いないもんね
ほとんど私聞いたことないですね僕も聞い
たことないあの僕の友人の克和さんもマキ
出身だけどマキいいよって言ってるもんね
やっぱりそうですよねうんでここら辺が
なんて言うんですかね同じこう人がやめて
いく組織にしても恨みを持ってみんなやめ
ていってる組織と本当にここいてよかった
なと思ってやめていく組織って全然違うん
だと思うんですよねなるほどでおそらく
同じ業界を見てもこの会社で働いてて本当
良くなかったって思うような人たちもいる
会社もあるんだと思うんですよ一方でマキ
ゼみたいに本当に良かったと思う会社って
いうのがあってこれがやっぱりその会社と
してどういうパーパスを持ってるかとか
どれだけ人のことを考えて育成をしてるの
かっていうところに現れてくるんじゃない
かなっていう気がしますねなるほどその差
を作っているものって何ですかやっぱり
会社の譲れないこうまパーパスと言います
か倫理感みたいうんところがすごくあると
思いますねうんあの例えば金星の場合って
いうのはまクライアントファーストという
ことと同時にですね人を育てるってことを
会社の1番重要な倫倫理感に置いてるん
ですよあそうなんだはいああそれ興味ある
ちょっと詳しくきまししてうんでも何を
するにしてもあるいは何ま査定とか年に何
回かありますけれども査においてもこの2
つに乗っ取ってるかどうかってのが1番の
重要なポイントなんですねお客に対して
責任を持つということと人を育てるという
この2つですね育うんでこの人を育て
るってことに対してはもちろんその車内の
研修もありますしこう日々のま同様だっ
たり上司からのフィードバックみたいな
ところも含めて徹底されてるんですよね
うん俺その2つすごい大事にしてるなです
よねうんアチーブメントすごい大事に
しするわその2つあのなので
アチーブメントのこう講座を受行しながら
いつも思うのはすごいマキ全にいてるなっ
ていうところ嬉しいあでやっぱりその
1人1人の能力を高めるために徹底して
こうトレーニングをしてフドバックをして
できるようになるまでこうずっとやり
続けるみたいなところっていうのもすごく
似てるなと思いながら見てます
[音楽]
ねあともう1つはやっぱり採用に対する
妥協がないかもしれないなうんマキ税って
いう会社はきっと
志しまいわゆる
あのアメリカ海軍のシールズのように志願
兵うんあれ志願兵を取っているからなん
だろうドロップアウトをしてく人でも
やっぱりもう1回チャレンジしようみたい
な人もいるしが国家に貢献しようっていう
意識でチャレンジしてるのでなんだろう
感謝の気持ちを持ってる人もいっぱいいる
じゃないですかはいマキ税っていう会社も
きっとマキゼに入るまでにすごい難易のが
あるからはいやっぱりそこら辺のところも
違うのかもしれないねうんそうかもしれ
ないですねうんまシールズなんかある意味
似てるかもしれないですねっと軍隊的と
いうかそうああでもあれですかあの
ちょっとこ関心があるんだけど今働き方
改革って言われるね時代の中で真金税って
結構ハードなんじゃないの働き方あの私も
マキ去ってからもう7年8年ぐらい経つの
であの今なのかわかんないですけれども私
が入った時はもうすごく働く組織でそう
はいもう1日24時間あったらどうしよう
かな22時間ぐらい働いた気がありますね
ちょ睡眠時間は取ってるんですけれども寝
てる間も考えないとこう進まないなって
いうぐらいこう追い詰められて仕事はして
ましたねあそうただあれがあったからこそ
今まその他の人ができないようなことも
ある意味当たり前にできてしまうっていう
とこがあってええその働き方改革という
ことが本当にその1人1人を育てる上で
いいのかどうかっていうのはま私個人の
体験としてはちょっと違うところもあるん
じゃないかなっていうのは感じてること
ですねいや僕はでもね本音を言うとね確か
に今そこなんだけれども人を鍛える本当に
人を
育てる本当に価値ある人間に育てるために
はその持たなければ与えられないので持つ
というプロの中でまいわゆる技術マインド
ノウハウスキルの
取得まさにその
この独学術じゃないけどやっぱり本気で
自分自身が求めてその価値ある人間になっ
て初めて人の力になれると思うのでそう
いうこうぐっと自分を高める期間っていう
のは必要なんじゃないかなっていうのは常
に僕はやっぱり持ってるし自分の人生を
振り返ってもやっぱり早く社会には出た
けれどもツワアワークアワーク時間の長さ
で買って仕事の量で買って密度で勝つま
こんなこと言うとどん引きされるんだけど
いや実際そうやって自分自身を鍛えてきた
なっていう感じを持ってるの
で実際この5つのねで学位を取るって言葉
で言うのは簡単だけど相当勉強してきた
でしょまそうですねそうでしょはいま白紙
論文確認ももう膨大な資業というか論文を
読み込まないと書けないのでそうはいそう
ですねま今回YouTubeにもねご紹介
させていただきましたありがとうございま
これからもね是非良いお互いに良い関係を
ね維持しながら共にね日本をよくしていき
ましょうありがとうございますどうも今日
はありがとうございましたございまし
たありがとうございますありがとうござい
ますこれまでになかなかない雰囲気で
面白いあそうなんですかもうちょっとこう
砕けた感じのうんやっぱインテリジェンス
を話し方から感じるもうそれはそうだね
うんで先ほどあの撮影前にも話してたん
ですけどあの高校の問題集未だに解かれ
てるということをそれすごい新鮮だよ高校
の問題集ってそれあの一般的な高校の問題
集でいいあそれで十分だと思いますね最初
は多分あの今共通テストって名前に変えて
変わってるんですけどあの昔のセンター
テストみたいな問題から解いていった方が
いいと思いますねはいなるほどあの
いきなりこう筆記で書こうとすると
なかなか難しかったり採点も難しかったり
するんでマーク式のこう選べばいいって
いうものをやっていくってのがいいと思い
ますねなるほどはいうんこれマッキデで
22時間働いてた時もやってたんですか
やってましたね
まその時の内容がこの本の土台になってる
んですけどあのマキ生でやっぱりあのま
なんて言うんですかね真金入った人って
やっぱり優秀な優秀なんですよだけど
みんなま私も含めて戸惑うんですよとうと
いうか壁に当たるんですよねでそこを超え
ていかないとコンサルタントとしてこう
成長しないっていう壁があった時にま私も
当然同じような壁にぶつかったんですけど
どうやったらそのコンサルタントとしての
スキルを上げられるだろうか考うんたに
気づいたこととしてはだから何なのって
いうこととなんでそう考えるのってこの2
つの問いかけがものすごい多いことに
気づいたんですよへえだから何なのていう
こととはいとなんでそう思うのとなぜなぜ
てことです思なぜそう思はいこの2つだけ
でほとんど車内のコミュニケーションも
成り立ってるしあとマキの場合パワー
ポイントにすごいあの落として落とし込む
んですけどパワーポイント作る段階でもだ
から何なんだっていうこととなんでそそう
なんだってことを自問自としながらこう
作っていくんですよってことを気づいてこ
れって何かに似てるなと思った時に高校の
現代文だと思ったんですよなるほどはいで
現代例えば東大の原種問題ってうん
おそらく9割5分ぐらいこの2つだけなん
ですよここれはどういうことかっていう
問題となぜこう言えるのかってこの2つ
だけで立ってるんですようんこれを
トレーニングするともしかしたら論理力
ってすごいつくんじゃないかなって考えて
自分で問題を解き始めてあ確かにそうだっ
ていうので確信を得てこの本書いたんです
よねなるほどはい
うこれ肝なと肝だねうんやっぱ仕さんは
仮説を立ててそれを検証せずにはいられ
ない立ちなんだなっていうのすご感じそう
あとその問題書がいいのがやっぱり
フィードバックが必ずあるじゃないですか
その答えを間違えた間違えてないでそう
すると自分のこう思考の歪みみたいな
ところに気づくんでうんというところが
すごくいいですねなので未だにあのZ会と
かも今やってたりしますねあとリクルート
のスタディサプリとかうはい新しい知識は
出てくるんですかそれは出てきますねへえ
あの私今一応その公文社からあのま今年末
か来年ぐらいにあの経済学士の本を出すん
ですけどうんそれを書く上でもやっぱり
その手元には教科書置いててでそれを見
ながらあこういうことかっていうの考えな
からク付けしているっていう感じです
ねいきなり難しい本を書こうと思っても
書けないんで
うーんいうことをずっとやってますね全て
の土台なんですねもあのマスター
プログラムとかにすごい似てる価値観だと
思いますけどねこれ自分で手を動かし
ながら考えて何回も何回もやってでその上
でこう思考のなんて言うんですかね
フィードバックをしていくっていうような
のにすごい似てると思いますねうんで
あそこに書かれてることも1つ1つはま
当たり前のことじゃないですか第2証言を
優先するとかはいうんだけどその当たり前
のことがああいうワークをずっとやらない
とできないんだと思うのでそには共通し
てると思いますけどねうんうんなるほど
なるほど
素晴らしい逆にとさんはあのずっとアメト
行かないってなってたところからなぜ行こ
うってなったんですかいやこれあの2年前
ずっと断ってたんですよで2年前に独立し
た時にちょっと社長にはお伝えしたかも
しれないですけどまある程度のその
キャリアもできてまあの営業しなくても
こう呼ばれてこう仕事ができるみたいな
環境になった時にふと自分これ楽しいのか
なと思ったんですよねで朝起きて今日は何
をする日なんだみたいなことを考えた時あ
何もないなみたいな感じになった時に
なんか自分のこう目的意識がなかったり
あとその世の中にこう還元しようっていう
気持ちがやっぱり薄らいでるなってのを
感じたん
うんでこれはきついなと思ってあれだけ嫌
だったアチーブメントある意味職業法的に
使おうかと思ってなるほど大月先生と話し
て初宿したってのが去年の今あの去年1年
ちょっとぐらい前の話です
ねで最初はあのま学者でもあり
コンサルタントでもあるんであの否定じゃ
ないですけどこう批判的には見てるんです
よね何かをこう言い任してやろうと思って
あの長
んう反論考えれば考えるほどあそうだよ
なって思う気づきがこう増えてですね結果
としてはあの今にってるって感じですね
全てのプログラムを学んでくれた
アシスタントにで入ってくる明日からまた
入ります
けどでもやっぱりそういう方々にも日の
内所がないって言われると自信思てますね
本当にまでも基本的にはを伝えてることは
原理原則なのでだからまある意味で逆にね
新しい何かノウハウとかなんか特別な秘策
があるのかとかっていう風にそれを求める
とないという風に感じる人もいるでも大事
なことはそれを実行してますかって言われ
た時に多くの人は実行できていない自分に
気づくわけだよだ僕は例えば冬毎冬必ず奥
さん
に布団乾燥期で布団をあっため
るっていうことを実行してるわけだよねで
これは頭がいい悪いの問題じゃなくてうん
こう実行の中に僕なりの愛があるわけです
よでこれが僕は人生をより欲することだと
思ってるわけだそのまある意味でねなん
だろう実行まで落とし込んでいくだから
アチーブメントピラミッドの究極一貫性と
いうところのこの日々の実践で全てが完成
するこれが僕のある意味ではまあなん
だろう気づきというかね究極の悟りという
とちょっと表現が宗教っぽくなるのででも
究極がこの実践の質が人生の質を決め
るっていうのがま私の研修の主張なんだよ
ねだからまそこ究極おそらくひさんもなん
だろううんいろんな意味でこのピラミッド
の一貫性を今ねすっきりと通してるところ
からさらにあの社会への貢献これから
すごいあのポテンシャルが普通の人じゃ
ないからまさにあのこうやって飛んでくる
スーパーマンみたいいやいや
そんなけどだからこれからすごいと思い
ますようん先がまだ長いしねうんまあ是非
ね本当に頑張ってもらいたいなと思いまし
たありがとうございますありがとうござい
ます大変楽しい会でした